alors il y a plus de dix articles disponibles sur
n'hésite pas à me pendre aussi
vérifie d'une manière ou d'une autre qu'il y a quelque chose sur moi
Je n'ai pas non plus de mécanisme normal
non, par exemple, je sais ce qu'il y a à mon adresse
les inscriptions en Biélorussie me sont parvenues
ils cherchaient pour quelle question ils me cherchaient
premièrement je ne sais pas deuxièmement personne ne me le dit
Je ne donnerais pas de réponse, c'est-à-dire qu'ils vivaient là-bas
locataires effrayés qui Où
Untel vit, on ne sait pas, on est là
nous ne vivons jamais
scie
c'est mon passeport qui se termine à
vingt-septième année
mais le passeport de ma femme et de mon enfant
se termine la vingt-quatrième année
au début de vingt-quatre
le passeport du deuxième enfant a expiré à
la vingt-deuxième année, nous l'avons prolongé en
Ambassade du Bélarus à Varsovie et
prolongation pour un maximum de 2 ans
prolongé jusqu'à la vingt-quatrième année
J'ai pratiquement tous les passeports de ma famille
se termine à quatre heures deux
année
[musique]
mais il y a des situations où une personne est comme ça
quelqu'un allait à des funérailles pour voir ses proches Oui
ils ont été détenus et emprisonnés parce que
maintenant si vous retournez en Biélorussie
tu peux être emprisonné pour t'aimer
installé en 202
et de moi Conseils personnels Ce n'est tout simplement pas dans
ne partez en aucun cas
[musique]
maison
Ma mère me manque aussi, je ne t'ai pas vu non plus
maman de 5 ans
mais je comprends que ma mère ne sera pas là
c'est plus facile si je viens aussi
[musique]
sera emprisonné